[Music]
in powertrip news o submitted by and I
disagree geo is one point cooler than
David you just got here thank you so
much
he heavily agree thank you by the way I
love you so much I think you're 70
points cooler than David see
particularly a court ruled against the
judge who tortured a defendant with a
stun belt during trial what the [ __ ] is
a stun belt I knew you guys know this i
cani picture before my imagination is
ruined alright I picture a belt whip
where you [ __ ] take out like this and
it comes out and goes well [ __ ] at the
end as a Taser juice it's like it's a
stun whip stung with belt but it's
around your belt that's sick I hope it's
that tell me the details kill animals
hmm is that used to kill animals oh no
it's for jailers yeah it's I got that
part right
yeah you did let's try it but is it a
belt this is what it looks like you keep
pushing her you're funny
this time no oh it's like a it's like
one of those dogs shockers then it's not
fair
it's it's already on the inmate yeah
d-ring for belly chain also doesn't stun
you did you [ __ ] up it's like for those
multiple super killers huh yeah so he's
he's shot they defended three times at
the Sun Belt to silence him during his
own trial the judge gets the [ __ ]
remote control makes us that's tight no
the bailiff does but the judge orders
man who do you give him a charge please
really that's what he said
I think it's really really smart
damn hit him again not to use it like
like that but like you know somebody
lunges forward to try to hurt somebody
instead of time to shoot them you could
just delivers a 5,000 I'm sorry 50,000
volts shock which can cause seizures
heart problems or worse shocks sounds
like you would just [ __ ] yourself yeah
shocks can cause the word to urinate or
defecate or it could bring you back to
life and you know and by the way like
that by the way that's any [ __ ] taser
by the way just to let you know like I
think like when you word it like that or
limits warded they think like
specifically it's only that one any
taser will cause that so think about
yeah so the how the story goes when they
were okay so first of all this the
defendant he names Terry and he was
convicted on one count of soliciting the
sexual performance of a child online and
through text exchanges with a 15 year
old girl he was sentenced to 60 years in
prison
so during his trial the judge asked the
defendant if he planned to plead guilty
or not guilty and then that's when the
defendant said sir before I say that I
had the right to make a defense and he
pretty much paid him
I thought you're supposed to plea your
case and then go to the No
well so he said that he the he took an
issue with his defense attorney and with
the judge hmm the judge he wanted the
judge recused from the case from his
case Oh
hater and so that's when the judge said
mr. Morris I am giving you one warning
you will not make any additional
outbursts like that because he took that
as an outburst because two things will
happen number one I will either remove
you from the courtroom or I will use the
shock belt on you he said all right sir
then the judge said now are you going to
follow the rules and the defendant said
sir I've asked you to recuse yourself
and then the judge repeated are you
going to follow the rules and then
Morris said I have a lawsuit pending
against you that's when the judge said
hit him the problem is he didn't know
what recused men because I don't know
what that means and so that's why he
kept on speaking the judge doesn't know
or accuse me no the defendant defendant
yeah okay oh I don't know what that yeah
what does that mean it means judge get
out of here no it means the judges the
judges somehow biased against him and he
wants them taken off the case yeah
refuse yourself because you're you have
some sort of personal lives like bring
in another judge in fancy as you kill
jobs have killed yourself yeah what keep
your honour
and then he said the judge said are you
going to behave that ain't [ __ ] is what
he said back to himself every day do it
again
no then that's when Morris tried to
explain that he has a history of mental
illness but then the judge took that as
another outburst and he said hit him
again to the bailiff I think he's he's
he's out of funk concert oh listen to
the music yeah yeah yeah
he was listen to James Brown the judge
was like yeah I just like an ear buds on
yeah yeah so then after he was shot the
second time Morris said I have a history
of mental illness you're wrong for doing
this then the judge said are you going
to behave
Morris said you're torturing a mental
clinic patient I have agoraphobia I'm
under medication so then it was like
after the back and forth then the judge
ordered the bailiff to shotgun a third
time what is agoraphobia your chairs
there's no Ratna phobia 20r fear I think
it's a fear of being on public places
with a bunch of people or something
anything let me my bet $1,000
what's a culture yeah you're right fear
of places there's lots of thinking this
bet $1,000
hey babe spiders of places and
situations that might cause panic
helplessness or embarrassment it's great
at the core this guy he's a pedophile
right yeah he could be shot this guy
yeah yeah
I want to embed is he a convicted
pedophile was he guilty well he didn't
get to convict it to his case didn't go
there yet
didn't get to plea right well they did
say he was sentenced to six years in
prison so well that would be his
sentence because they're still in the
middle of the courtroom
I want to argue the other side of story
in defense of this man I have nothing
okay we should invent jaw shock oh the
jock shock is a better one well your
honor dick it's a it's like I like it
though it's like a underwears that
impossible exactly yeah and then and
then you [ __ ] like zap off their
[ __ ] penis off big good money maybe
you guys remember in Goodfellas but he
would like sliced that garlic really
thin yeah in the jail they should go to
their dick just like really [ __ ] we
gonna hire some Italian garlic guy yep
[ __ ] sliced dicks that's on a
different judge beside the shock him
again they ruled that it was
unconstitutional he violated the man's
right what about the judges bail of
black and you know there's a blue bail
there's no black bail man thin black
line yeah I don't think pedophiles
should have rights
well it's good so they're saying that
it's done stun belt is a device meant to
ensure physical safety it is not and
speaking out of turn
yeah yeah pretty much yeah but he was
about to [ __ ] a kid so it's okay it's
gonna be odd in the judges smoke room
when they're in there together you know
I admit what does it do they do the
hangout
they're all in there oh yeah I like how
they resemble a Japanese rice ball their
outfit their cape
they look like a big Japanese rice ball
thanks for that relatable reference I'm
wearing a [ __ ] Japanese rice ball
looks like a rug yeah it looks like a
rice like like triangle with a with a
black I'll be goddamned
yeah that's a judge right there that
looks like a judge
looks like [ __ ] on like a judge to
be yep yep judge on eg case closed
[Music]
what he looks Asian what what is he
black named Gallagher his hair looks
like a helmet
please don't say it here very good here
yeah wish I had this here
Jorge Gallagher yeah definitely zapping
him was probably way out of line
so he's under fire yeah is he still a
judge yeah he's chill he's moved it over
electric chair instead that's inhumane
to zap his [ __ ] arms and [ __ ]
yeah cuz they were using it like he was
using it more as an intimidation rather
than what it's meant for it which is in
the case it's like for safety in case
they like try to attack someone and then
they should strap the judge with that
thing in buzzing three times yeah let
the guy do it yeah call even-steven stop
it being the Stephens the even see I
I summon article 17 of even Stephens
bylaws and he's like that is the law I
think they should have a bitch-slap hand
where there's a defendant like on the
chair yeah and then like if the [ __ ]
judge is like shut the [ __ ] up they
pushed the button in the bitch-slap hat
and just it's like a jackass remember
that jackass thing I was like your best
thing the [ __ ] big hand [ __ ] oh man
I'm such a child I laugh at that enjoy
cry that was the funniest one funny man
he have to luncheon [ __ ]
we're such children I love it that's the
best no my favorite one was when like
yeah they throw the lab outside and they
punch ammonia oh that was good dude I
love this show where they had the jet
engines like from the plane oh yeah and
they were throwing footballs into it and
hitting each other in the nuts [ __ ]
incredible when they shot it in Porter
boyo oh yeah nothing ever beats they
don't ever come close to Japanese show
[ __ ] though dude like they literally get
somebody a [ __ ] cabin like in the
Alps of some [ __ ] right and they had
them in a bed and then the whole cabin
comes apart there's a [ __ ] live human
bungee strapped to a bed do they know
they were doing their dying this fall
were the grandpa he said sound like in
this lazy boy chair - kicked it with the
with the towel wrapped around his waist
cuz they're naked and then that [ __ ]
thing turns her out locks it down
Mobe like on a snow slope it's like it's
so weird what's happening they don't
know how to react how do you react you
think you're gonna die no gitans up like
in everybody else's mind club while he
just get off it's like what that she's
happening you don't know what the [ __ ]
they're doing is like what what is this
like what the [ __ ] I love cutting I
always love when they cut to the
audience through the eyes like yep it's
like man what was this guy expecting of
course do not exist in Japan when it
comes to comedy I love that I think it's
great I really did there's also this
other prank where they just had this guy
they laid traps where he just falls into
hot water and they do this guy's like
for a whole year even when he's giving
out a [ __ ] award I saw a video of
this very worried Japanese man with the
water jet pack on his back and he looked
like you didn't want to be there but I
loved them either before look it's
better than anything
[Music]
[Music]